i mean it's i'm not afraid of a real
confrontation if i genuinely feel
wronged
i just don't like over stuff like that
that's just so inconsequential and not
important
like it's not worth it like if it
involved my child or my dog or something
that was really like high stakes for me
yeah then yeah but it's like in that
moment that's so dumb
yeah also i'll just there's a little
growth moment too in hawaii i want to
bring up i guess
um it's not funny not to be funny yeah i
mean it's not a funny idea
right but there was this moment where um
you know
um and this is probably people maybe
listening can relate
that you're really hard on yourself
right
that if you if it's not perfect you you
you just rip on yourself and there's
like this internal monologue that you
play in your head you know i mean like
you're a piece of [ __ ] i do that
a lot do you do that yeah do you
do that all day long i think all about
except
yeah george had a great upbringing yeah
yeah you did it
that's why this happened you know this
is where you this is why you are
where you are you know i just have this
thing in my head you know i mean that
constantly yeah it's the flogging blaze
yeah
it's flogging i flogged myself and um
zach knight the actor that's on
magnum pi um who's interesting because
he was um
somebody that i've known never really
talked to really but it's somebody that
i'd like been
around since for 20 years because when i
was on
mad tv he was on a show called life on a
stick
do you know what life on the stick is
that the one with charlie yes
oh i remember so zack knight charlie
finn were the two guys
right in life and on a stick is that
about like a hot dog
hot dog yeah hot dog on a stick at a
mall right
right which is weird what a weird
premise but i like it yeah it's cool
and then who else who's on it is who
we're going to have on the podcast
soon is maz germany he plays the manager
on the show
okay so um i was sitting there and there
was a scene where i was in a
[ __ ] um van
so imagine it's really hot you're in
hawaii right
and i had these all these technical
lines i had to do it was like weird the
way it was written and it was long and i
had to say it fast because i'm on a
computer
so you know a lot of times when you're
doing something like that it's just like
i like conversational things
you know gilbert how are you you know i
mean
i can memorize whatever but when it
comes to stuff like you know technical
stuff like computer
words that are like you know like the
hacker stuff hacker stuff you know i
mean
i don't know the words so it's like i
have to memorize the sound of the word
because i don't know what the word is
you understand what i'm saying would it
help if you looked up the meaning
it doesn't matter because if i've never
heard of it right i'm still memorizing
sound you know instead of meaning
no what i'm saying is the sentence you
are reciting or memorizing
would um would be easier to remember
if you understood what you were saying
if you understood the meaning of what
the words you were saying you remember
the word i'm curious now
no i i can't even that's how i removed
it removed it is i don't even know the
words because i had to memorize the
sound of them yeah
it wasn't just one it was just the way
it was a lot a lot of law references all
even different things right
yeah i can do it right but not you know
in a van when it's super hot right
and and they're like the sun's going
down yeah
and they're like we got to get the shot
i mean yeah we gotta
come on you know what i mean you have
all that going and i thought i was doing
pretty good
last couple days and i was i was doing
and there was this one moment and i
wasn't [ __ ] up but like i had this
little big chunk of thing and halfway
during it i just blanked
i just blanked i just couldn't remember
what the next thing was
instead of going and most actors they go
line and then you know the lady behind
me goes it's this you know it's not a
big deal
but instead of doing that i just went i
stopped like
i stopped and i put my head down and i
just said i'm i can't
i'm done you said you're done yeah
that's the growth moment no no
i feel like you're you might have
regrets
no no she regrets it
no then zach knight he's in the front
seat
he turns around and he says
look at me he goes look at me i look at
him he goes you're
killing it we love you here
you do everyone makes mistakes right
you're doing a great job
start start from the top and that
i don't get emotional but you know when
actors do that you know
to help you out in a situation you know
oliver hudson did that
when we did um splitting up together i
love him i love him too
so when zach did that a little too much
me too all right babe
you want to suck his dick i get it but
um he's a family man
but um when he did that it was just like
oh you know what i mean but what a nice
gesture so that that happened as well i
just beat myself i just shut down
i go i [ __ ] i hate this you know i mean
i i'm an
idiot yeah you know
it's not funny really but did you get it
right after that
no no but babe i really don't
[Laughter]
yeah like even if let's say you go in
for an audition and even if you don't
get the part
yeah um if you had an overall like
supportive and positive
um environment at that audition yeah
you i shine you you really shine and and
you also
want to go back almost immediately yeah
like yeah i mean there are there are
some environments where if it's
cold and empty and there's a feeling of
there's no feeling there
and i and i feel trapped right yeah i'm
terrible
well we freeze when we we were kids that
were beat
yeah it's like we freeze in that high
pressure moment it's like all we want to
do is either
fight or flight and or freeze
yeah and then we're not all in our brain
anymore like our blood has flowed to
all flowing through like our periphery
and nothing is up there anymore in her
head yeah yeah
that's what yeah and it's like i would i
think i would have been able to do it
even if
the director was like because you know
robocop was there
oh the you had a really rough experience
with him yes a robocop was there but he
wasn't directing
my episode oh i was just there he would
know he was directing the episodes
after mine but he was just prepping
right but he was in my hotel room
so that was another thing you know i
mean a challenge of mine during my days
off
is to avoid robocop let's remind the
audience what happened with robocop last
night so rob
okay so robocop he's a great actor
robocop is a great actor peter weller
peter weller okay
and he's a great director he's
everything he's at the top of his
field